good afternoon everybody
hey so today in the Press briefing we
are saying goodbye to two are of our
amazing interns I think they're here
somewhere oh there they go uh Kate
Howell and Molly Feldman they have been
great great additions to additions to
our team uh these past several months
and they are now going back to school
hopefully enjoying the holiday before
you go back to school but thank you so
much for your hard work and today we
have a familiar face with us to talk
about how the president's winter
preparedness plan on covid-19 increases
as kova 19 increases as the holiday as
we head into the holidays and so Dr Zha
is here to talk about this plan and take
some questions as well right
thank you kjp good afternoon everyone
um good to be with all of you again as
expected we're seeing covid Rising
across the country this winter
and while covet isn't the disruptive
force it once was
we are focused on ensuring that the U.S
is prepared for this winter no matter
what the virus throws at us
as you know we have the tools we have
the infrastructure and we have the
know-how to manage this moment
and that means protecting people
preventing hospitalizations and deaths
want this winter to look like last
winter or the winter before
and our winter covid-19 preparedness
plan helps us do just that so how do we
do that
first and you're not going to be
surprised to hear me say this the most
important thing Americans can do is they
go get their updated kobit 19 vaccine
right away now you heard this from Dr
fauci just before Thanksgiving you heard
this from me
and I will repeat again the updated
covid-19 vaccine is your best protection
against the version of covid we're
fighting right now
second a critical component of our
winter plan is making it even easier for
Americans to access the tools that will
protect them this holiday season
vaccines tests and treatments so let's
talk about tests today we're opening up
covetest.gov for a limited time this
winter to give Americans another easy
option to access testing when there is a
greater need as there is right now
starting today each U.S household can
order up to four at-home tests free from
kovittest.gov with tests starting to
ship as early as next week
the week of December 19th
and as we've said for months
we're operating in a resource
constrained environment
in the absence of additional
Congressional funding for the nation's
coveted response and that means we've
had to make some tough choices
like in the summer we were forced to
suspend the covetest.gov program so we
could preserve our tests
why did we want to preserve our tests
because we knew there would be a moment
later in the year when covet cases would
rise again
so we kept we preserved the tests so we
could have them on hand for exactly this
moment
and if we don't get more funding we
won't be able to send more tests out to
the American people
next we're standing ready to support
States and communities with medical
personnel supplies and other resources
as the president has been committed to
doing since the first state he took
office today secretary Becerra is Right
sending out a letter to all governors
underscoring that our partnership with
state and local leaders has been
essential to fighting this virus
but the secretary also made clear we
need them to step up right now to get
ahead of this increase in covid that we
are seeing across the country and he
outlined all of the federal supports
available to set up more vaccination
sites more pop-up clinics to get more
shots in arms to expand tests to
treatment programs including new tested
tree programs sites that are that the
federal government can help with to make
key supplies like at-home tests widely
available and things that the federal
government can do to support hospitals
and Health Systems as needs arise
because the bottom line is this
We're All in This Together
fourth we are accelerating our efforts
to protect the highest risk Americans
building on the considerable steps we
have taken
now I want to remind everybody that more
than 90 percent of covet deaths in the
US have occurred in people 50 years of
age or older
and in recent months we've seen covet
deaths really concentrated among those
65 and above
and while we've seen many older
Americans step up and get the updated
covet vaccine there's still too many
older Americans who have not gotten
their immunity updated who have not
gotten themselves protected
under half of nursing home residents
have gotten their updated covert vaccine
so we are working very closely with
leadership of nursing homes Across
America and we have asked them to step
up to do more we've developed a winter
playbook for nursing homes and long-term
care facilities to help them take action
to make it easier to get vaccines on
site in nursing homes to make sure that
treatments are available on site in
nursing homes to improve indoor air
quality another strategy that can make a
really big difference
and we are reaching out to Governors
where nursing home vaccination rates are
low to offer personalized support
now before taking your questions let me
close with this
we don't want this winter to look like
last winter or the winter before
and it doesn't have to
what's different is that we have an
updated vaccine that targets a version
of the virus we're fighting
but we need people to get that vaccine
it's free and widely available
we what's different this winter compared
to last winter is we have highly
effective treatments that are widely
available if people get sick but
obviously we need doctors to prescribe
them we need people to get them
this winter we can keep people safe we
can prevent hospitalizations and deaths
we can minimize disruptions
the Administration has been has been
planning for this moment we are doing
our part we're prepared but the bottom
line is we need other leaders to step up
as well Governors Mayors people who've
been terrific Partners throughout this
entire pandemic but here's what I know
if every American does their part if
every American goes out and gets an
updated vaccine if every American gets
treated who's eligible for treatment
we can have a very different winter
ahead and that is a goal of this effort
so with that let me stop take questions
and kjp I'll turn it back to you
thank you Dr
moving out from the U.S borders for just
a second certainly one of the risks that
faces this nation is additional spread
from a big outbreak in China
you give us a sense of whether the U.S
government was
aware or made aware in advance that
paxilvid would be would be made
available in China and can you give us
any sense of what talks are happening
behind the scenes
rather to help get Western vaccines and
internet yeah so on the specific
question of paxilvid the US government
was not involved in any way uh and it
was so really refer you to Pfizer
um and but we were not involved in that
in any way shape or form on the broader
question you're raising Jeff what I
would say is this and since the
beginning of this Administration the
president has been very clear that we
think it's really important uh for the
world to benefit from the fruits of the
of American scientific innovation we
have been the largest donor of vaccines
in the world almost 700 million doses
many bilateral many through Kovacs and
the president's been very clear We Stand
ready to help any country that needs
help uh in terms of vaccines treatments
anything else so that that offer stands
globally for any country that could
benefit from it to characterize this as
the U.S and other Western countries are
encouraging China to import mRNA
vaccines but not necessarily with U.S or
strong U.S employment does that give
them cover that they need so what I
would say is We Stand ready to help any
country in the world with vaccines
treatments anything else that we can be
helpful with we have been the biggest
donor of vaccines as I said almost 700
million doses uh and that that stance of
being helpful being ready to help
continues and hasn't changed
he's Dr looking at the most recent
coveted numbers we have it looks like
coveted cases were up uh 45 and 50 week
over week last week but coveted deaths
were up 60
why are coveted why are coveted deaths
spiking more dramatically than Copic
cases are yeah it's a good question um
so some of that is by the way data right
irregularity just to be clear the data
is just we're in a different place with
data would get data less often so in
general we have seen coveted cases go up
we've seen hospitalizations go up
um deaths are just starting to rise I do
think that that standard link we've seen
between cases and deaths are going to be
different because there's less testing
so we're going to be it's going to be
later to see cases go up
um but so far nationally in our analysis
of the data death numbers are just
beginning to rise we obviously want to
make sure that does not go any further
we know we can prevent nearly every
death from covid if people get their
updated vaccines and people get treated
so we continue to press that message
considering a return to other
restrictions you know masking on planes
vaccine requirements yeah so I think
we're in a very different place with
this virus and where we were two years
ago where we were last year what I would
say is we now have the tools that we can
manage Our Lives much more safely than
we could couple of years ago and the
most important thing I think people need
to be doing is first of all they've got
to get their updated vaccines and then
there's a whole host of tools that
people can use to keep themselves or
family safe testing masking improving
indoor air quality being in better
ventilated places
um
oh and treatments of course so
we think that is the strategy of the
administration that we want to encourage
people to use those tools and given how
widespread and how available those tools
are
um I think if people did that we could
get through this winter safely
just to follow up on Jeff's question uh
with China relaxing is zero
nutrition have
um to deal with a potential outbreak or
new variants particularly with the
increase of travel between the US and
China and during the holidays and in the
Lunar New Year and do those
considerations at this point include any
talks of a travel ban
yeah so um
we have a very robust surveillance
program that where we use for travelers
as people come in uh in terms of
identifying people who are infected
tracking variants uh that continues
um and we generally are using Wastewater
using other mechanisms constantly
monitoring for variants both here as
well as with our partners around the
world in Europe and in South Africa in
other places I think all of that is a
really important part of how we have
become far more effective at being
prepared for new variants and if there
are new variants that emerge I'm
confident that we will be able to
identify them
doctors are we still facing a triple
damage where RSV flew and covet are all
surging at once over the holidays yeah
so we we have seen certainly in the last
month three highly contagious
respiratory viruses
um as you mentioned RSV flu and covid
let me tell you what we know about them
RSV nationally looks like it has clearly
peaked and it's on its way down
um there's still places that have a very
high levels of RSV you're still but but
nationally there's no question in my
mind RSV is heading down you know flu is
rising in many parts of the country
we're probably the worst flu outbreak
we've seen in a decade there and there
are some places where flu may be peaking
but it's very early data but a lot of
flu out there again the worst in a
decade and then we talked about covid
where clearly it's on an uh upswing with
increasing number of cases one other
question back in September the president
publicly said that the pandemic is over
how has that complicated the messaging
to keep Americans Vigilant they yes I
think the president was also very clear
that covet is not over can covet
continue to pose a challenge for us that
is true the covet is not over and and
obviously we continue to see people
getting infected getting sick
unfortunately too many Americans
needlessly dying of covid uh and so I
think the president has been very clear
on this even since uh that day about the
importance of people getting vaccinated
people getting treated and obviously
I've been out here making that same
message
one is there are there particular hot
spots right now you're concerned about
when it comes to covid rise and then
secondly based on all three of the
viruses you've been discussing can you
talk to us about the strain on the
nation's hospitals
um so particular hospitals we're seeing
cases increase in about 90 of the
country so it is real sort of rising in
lots of places across the country
um so there's not one that I'm I think
is in you know is particularly uh worse
off um obviously the very you know the
levels are different across the country
but it is rising pretty much uniformly
and it makes sense right we just had the
Thanksgiving holidays it's getting
colder even in the southern parts of the
country it's still getting colder
obviously we tend to see more in the
northern half of the country because it
is colder up here people are spending
more time indoors in terms of Hospital
strain this is something we monitor very
very closely we look at a whole bunch of
National Data every day we are talking
to States and jurisdictions every day
about every state and every jurisdiction
every day but on an ongoing basis I
would say in the last 10 days I have
probably spoken to I or members of my
team a dozen or more states and cities
and and our first question is how are
the hospitals doing do you need more
help there we have a very clear plan uh
if a city or a state gets in trouble
where they really just can't manage uh
that they can reach out to the federal
government we have a whole set of
resources if that we can value it we can
send in equipment we can send in
Personnel so we stand ready to help
cities and states if and or when they
need it
um obviously the single most important
thing we can do to make sure that there
aren't constraints and there aren't real
problems with Hospital capacity is that
people got vaccinated they are far less
likely to get hospitalized for both flu
and covid and that's the biggest thing
Americans can do to make sure their
hospitals are functional for all the
other reasons we need hospitals Karen
last one um are you concerned that
Americans who are testing positive but
doing so on at-home rapid tests aren't
reporting that to government agencies so
the case counts right now might be
dramatically lower than what we're
actually seeing for spread across the
country yeah it's a really good question
what I would say is first of all I'm a
huge fan of Home tests I think you know
they're convenient they're cheap it's
great one of the problems of of Home
tests really the major problem is that
they don't often get reported so we do
have through this NIH effort called
makemytestcount.gov I think that people
can report their tests but we have other
mechanisms we use to monitor infection
levels so for instance Wastewater gives
us very good insights into how much
infection there is in a community so we
have seen case numbers often be lower
than what you might expect if people
were doing more PCR tests or more Public
Health tests but we're tracking
infections through other mechanisms and
obviously we're tracking infections and
and hospitalizations so that that gives
us a very good sense of the burden of
disease as well the last point I will
make is when people test at home if they
test positive the first thought every
single American should have is am I
eligible for treatment the truth is we
have fantastic treatments anybody over
the age of 50 anybody with chronic
disease should get evaluated personally
as a physician I think it's very clear
to me that anybody in their 60s or above
should be treated like there should be a
good reason not to treat somebody
and they're rarely a good reason meaning
most people should be getting treated
right now and that is a message we've
been delivering to doctors and nurses
that's the message we've been
challenging the American people if you
get a positive test at home
stay away from others so you don't
infect them and get evaluated to get
treated
to their houses were there cuts to other
covid programs in order to pay for those
tests yeah so let me talk about
um how we're able to do this so we
paused the program you know at the end
of the summer because we wanted to make
sure that we still had Supply
for a winter potential increase of cases
in the winter
um second is while we as I have
mentioned from here before while we took
a lot of the resources we had for tests
to purchase vaccines
um and treatments we still had some
resources left we didn't use to deplete
the whole Supply and so we had money in
the American Rescue plan uh to still be
able to buy some more tests that
combination has allowed us to do this it
is on a limited basis We're not gonna be
able to keep this open forever
hey JP thank you very much and thanks
everybody
okay
just a couple things at the top and then
we'll take some questions so today is
the final day of the U.S Africa leader
Summit a summit that has underscored the
U.S commitment to reinvigorating
Partnerships across the continent
President Biden vice president Harris
and other officials across the
administration have had the opportunity
to spend a lot of time with the leaders
from across Africa over the last couple
of days including at last night's dinner
here at the White House
now this afternoon the president will
address the summit one more time at this
afternoon's discussion on food security
and food system resilience this week
President Biden and vice president
Harris have had the opportunity to
announce new initiatives that will
Empower African institutions and
citizens the president reaffirmed our
resolve to work collaboratively with
African governments businesses and civil
Civil Society to strengthen
people-to-people ties ensure more
inclusive and responsive Global
institutions build a strong and
sustainable global economy Foster new
technology and Innovative strengthen
Innovation strengthen Health Systems and
prepare for the next pandemic tackle the
food security and climate Crisis Support
democracy and human rights and Advance
peace and security the Biden Harris
Administration plans to commit at least
55 billion dollars in Africa over the
next three years working closely with
Congress and more than 15 billion
dollars in private sector investment
deals were announced at the U.S Africa
business forum and of course you've
heard the president announce this week's
plan this this week plans this week well
this week to plan to travel to Africa
and to continue the work over the course
of of the summit and to strengthen our
partnership across the continent
I also want to talk about something that
affects millions of people across the
country every day
and with the holiday season upon us and
in the light of the tragic news about
twitch this week
we think it's important that we shed
light on the resources available to any
American dealing with mental health
challenges or emotional distress
tomorrow said the second gentleman
second gentleman Douglas emhoff and
leaders from Department of Health and
Human Services will visit a local 988
call center and meet with crisis
counselors who are providing mental
health and suicide prevention support to
people from all backgrounds and walks of
life
the 988 suicide and prevention Lifeline
provides free confidential 24 7 support
to Americans across the country
experiencing suicidal crisis or severe
emotional distress anyone anywhere in
the country can call or text 988 or chat
988lifeline.org to reach a live trained
counselor
and thanks to the president our
Administration has invested
432 million dollars in getting the 988
suicide and crisis Lifeline up and
running in communities across the
country and 18-fold increase investment
from the previous administration so
before we go into questions I'll repeat
myself one last time here for all of you
all of those who are struggling we stand
with you in our Administration will keep
fighting for you one last thing before
we well let's say we really take
questions is I want to take a give you
guys a little bit of the week ahead just
a quick look here this evening the
president will travel to Wilmington
Delaware tomorrow the president will
visit and speak at a town hall at the at
the major Joseph R Beau Biden III
National Guard Reserve Center in
Newcastle Delaware this is a Capstone on
the department of vet Veterans Affairs
pact act week of action with over 90
events and Counting held across the
country to encourage veterans to sign up
for Health Care get screened for toxic
exposure and submit a claim if they are
experiencing a toxic exposure related
condition the president will speak with
veterans their families caregivers and
survivors to discuss the historic
expansion of benefits and services
resulting from the bipartisan pact act I
anticipate a preview with more details
will be shared ahead of the event so
please stay tuned to that afterwards the
president will return to Washington DC
for internal meetings and a more holiday
receptions
Friday evening the president will return
to Wilmington Delaware where he will
remain over the weekend on Monday the
president will return to Washington D.C
and in the evening he and the first lady
will host a Hanukkah holiday reception
at in the grand foyer right here in the
White House and the residents to be more
precise we'll have more to share on next
week's guidance in the coming days but
we can also confirm today that next
weekend the president and first lady
will celebrate Christmas at the White
House and with that Zeke you want to
kick us off
I'm hoping you can shed some light on me
apparent radio miscommunication that
kept the White House Press pool with
separate press pulls from the
president's Burger King in the white
house today
yes
for sure on
um so there was no emergency just to be
clear or a security situation and it
appears that there was a radio
miscommunication upon upon departure
Vance picked up the White House staff
and press that were left at the
convention center so also White House
staff were also left as well and we
waited to to start the Press briefing
until everyone returned to the White
House we share an appreciation for how
important it is for the Press pool to
travel with the president and this
remains a priority for our entire team
we sincerely apologize for the confusion
and inconvenience and just to reiterate
we also sadly left White House staff as
well at the convention center so this
was this was a uh it was not just uh the
Press so just wanted to make that clear
again but with all seriousness we do
apologize for that the president in his
remarks earlier alluded to a trip to uh
to Africa itself to give details on when
he might go and where he might go and I
know that Jake spoke to this when he was
here on on Monday as well look I don't
have anything to to share at this time
uh what I can say is and this is
basically what Jake said on Monday is
that the vice president a number of
cabinet officials they're all looking
forward to visiting the African
continent in 2023 just don't have
anything to preview at this time sorry
I'm back on
talked a lot about the importance of
Americans getting vaccinated with the
CDC data shows that you know only that
percent of America
president believe that he or his
administration Bears some responsibility
for not being able to convince the vast
majority of Americans to get these
updated shots that hurt Dr John are so
important well let's not forget Sequim
when the president walked into the
administration he put forth a
comprehensive covid vaccination uh plan
uh that that would did not exist before
he stepped into the into the
administration that helped get more than
200 million Americans across the country
fully vaccinated and also made sure that
there was Equity at the center of his
plan look we're in a different phase as
we you've heard us say in this pandemic
and and we are going to encourage people
to get that new vaccine we have the
tools we have the tools that we know
work uh when it comes to covid when it
comes to this pandemic and uh and we're
going to continue to let folks know to
utilize those tools and so you've seen I
as I started this briefing saying we're
seeing a familiar face uh in the Press
briefing room and that's because we've
been trying to be very consistent on
pushing that message out and letting
people know that they need to get the
new vaccine it is important we know it
works especially as they're going to see
their grandparents as they're going to
see Families how important it is to get
that new vaccine for themselves but also
for their loved ones look we believe
we've had a a comprehensive message
we've had a comprehensive plan but again
we're in a new phase of this of this
pandemic and we just have to continue to
beat the drum and we'll continue to do
that
thanks Chris I'm on immigration we've
talked to so many border patrol agents
and leaders who are just really worried
and anxious about the possibility of
title 42 ending next week big picture
what is the administration doing right
now to get ready for that so A couple of
things that I want to lay out and I kind
of laid this out before but um I want to
reiterate it here is that um you know
we're doing the work we're going to do
this in a safe and humane way and we'll
we will have more to share on the
proposed preparedness next week before
the December 21st uh date but uh look we
also need Congress to act it is
important that they deliver the
resources we requested for the border
security and management they need to
pass the comprehensive immigration
reform that we have put forth on day one
the president put forth a comprehensive
uh reform plan that dealt with
protecting uh for protecting for
dreamers cutting down the Asylum the
Asylum build up that we have been seeing
especially because of what what the last
Administration did and they completely
gutted the system and we know that this
has been a multi-decade long problem we
need to modernize the system and this is
something that the president has put
forth and we are looking for Congress to
act we are asking Congress to act and so
uh but in the meantime what we have been
able to do is the president as I've
mentioned before has secured uh historic
funding we have 23 000 border security
agents at the border and that is the
most amount that we've ever had and
that's because of what the president has
been able to do and we have worked to
launch a historic anti-smuggling
operations that are taking thousands of
Smugglers off the streets but look the
reality is we need Congress to take
action we need to do this in a
bipartisan way as we have done as the
president has been able to do more than
200 times during his administration
there's been some reporting out there
that the administration is considering
changes to the Asylum policy potentially
making so only
apply for Asylum if they've already been
denied for another country like Mexico
is that true is the administration
considering any changes to policy so
look I know there's a lot of rumors out
there about that a lot of speculation
don't have anything to announce at this
time or from here at this time uh what I
would encourage people to do is to read
the Department of Homeland Security they
put out they put forth a six point plan
on how they're going to move forward
with dealing with dealing uh when we're
dealing with the post December 21st
deadline when title 42 indeed lives but
don't have anything more to announce
about a any any new plans from here
that's great
um DHS warns in a memo obtained by CNN
this week but the end of title 42 will
quote likely increase migration flows
immediately into the U.S so I'm
wondering how many migrants are you
expecting to try and cross into the U.S
through the southern border next week
and
um and is the administration prepared
for this anticipated search so look you
know
we have we have an intensive all of
government effort underway to prepare uh
as I was stating earlier uh when I was
being asked a question by Mary we'll
have more to share ahead of the 20 the
December 21st deadline but in the
meantime DHS is surging resources to the
Border as you've seen as you're probably
seeing it in El Paso I talked a little
bit about this on on Monday where where
over the last 72 hours they've moved
thousands of individuals out of uh out
out of the city they're doubling down on
the anti-smuggling operations that the
president launched months ago they're
also working with our International
Partners to discourage disorderly mass
movements across the border moving
forward expect us to continue leaning in
on our successful strategies like these
and like our parole program for
Venezuela Nationals which has
drastically reduced the number of
Venezuelans attempting to enter
unlawfully and will continue to drive
messaging in the region to counter
disinformation from mugglers so that's
another thing that we you know we have
to keep an eye on is how the
misinformation that's going to be going
out to Smugglers in the next couple of
days and so we have to make sure we'll
work together with all of you our team
will to make sure that that doesn't
happen because that is one of the big
issues that we're seeing when it comes
to migrants trying to cross over are you
aware of this warning from DHS and do
you have an estimate of how many people
you're expecting will try and cross the
border when Title 42. look I don't have
an estimate to share with you what I can
tell you is that the Department of
Homeland homeland security has put out a
six-point plan as you all know my
secretary Marcus was at the border just
recently to talk about this plan put out
a statement and so we are focused we are
focused and we are prepared and we will
have more to share in the next coming
days on this on this piece but again we
have we have done the work from this
Administration by securing record record
funding and we are asking Congress for
Congress to act we are not we are not
asking for political stunts we continue
to see political stunts from many
Republicans out there and that's not how
we're going to fix this issue they want
to they want to secure the Border we've
been doing that work on our own and we
ask we're asking them to hey you know
what there's an immigration reform plan
that the president put out on the first
day they should work with us and do this
in a bipartisan way and then in terms of
the funding negotiations on Capitol Hill
we've seen this Administration as
president at times play a more Hands-On
role a more hands-off role in some
negotiations depending on the situation
what's the case with these negotiations
how involved has the president been
which particular negotiations are you
are you talking about spending the
spending oh the spending the Omnibus
Bill more broadly uh so look we're
encouraged by the bipartisanship that
we're currently seeing uh to to the
progress that we're seeing in Congress
uh from leaders and and the progress
that they're making so it's a key step
on the path to a full year Government
funding bill that delivers for the
American people we're optimistic uh that
members of both parties can build on
this progress and produce a funding bill
that can pass the house and send it
signed into law by by the president but
to your question though look the
president has been very engaged uh he's
been talking to Congressional members he
had the big four here not too long ago
and this was in the readout this was the
government funding was uh the main
priority that they discussed and we have
our team here we have a Shalonda Young
from OMB I've mentioned this before
who's the director who has been playing
point on this who knows how to work
across a lot across the across the aisle
and do things in a bank bipartisan way
and she is leading that effort along
with our office of ledge Affairs who
have had multiple calls multiple
meetings in getting this done look this
was done in bipartisan way last year and
we believe it can be done in a
bipartisan way this year as well
we we I mean we have said I said this
earlier uh you know if Congress needs a
little bit more time to get this done uh
where they should take that time but we
believe there's enough time to get the
Omni Omnibus done uh and so we are we
are encouraged by what we're seeing in
in that progress and we believe that it
can get done in time
but I just don't know sixth grade the
president mentioned in his statement
yesterday about the Sandy Hook killings
the anniversary again his pushed for an
assault weapons ban and also talked
about
um
moral deal and not having done more over
the last 10 years
there's only a couple weeks left for the
lame duck can you give us an update on
just what the next steps are that he
sees for this white house for this
Administration and getting that assault
weapons man so look we have been in
close touch with Senate leadership on
this as you as you've just mentioned
this is a priority for this President it
has been for some time he was a leader
on this during his Senate days and also
as vice president and so he's going to
continue to push for this whether this
happens in the next couple of weeks or
it happens in the next several months he
is going to really work hard to get this
done and um you know he's he's talked
about it at almost every moment that he
can every time that he had an
opportunity to talk about uh the the
shootings that we have seen how it's
destroyed our communities how it's
destroyed families he's going to
continue to lift that up to the American
people again we're going to have those
conversations with Senate leadership we
have been the last couple of days uh
don't have a timeline for you this is
indeed a priority for this President and
his administration we have seen the work
that he's done this first year and a
half he did the most did the most
executive actions uh on gun violence
than any other president and so clearly
this is a priority for this president
think about it is it is it really that
is the strategy basically to use the
bullet I mean there are other steps
that's an important strategy I mean
right the president has one of the most
powerful bully pulpits in the country in
the world even right and so uh we've
seen him use it in an effective way to
get historic historic pieces of
legislation done and so he's going to
continue to do that but we're also
having conversations with Senate
leadership that will not stop or end
when it comes to this issue
thanks green
um just before you came out the
president had authorized the release of
documents related to John F Kennedy's
assassination
um and since you've been at the podium
the National Archives has started
posting those documents you talk about
that decision to to release those and
also address
um 70 of the documents are being
released 30 still or not what is taking
so long in the other 30 given it's been
50 years so look as you know this was
has been a commitment of this President
right uh the president the president's
actions have led to public release of
over 14 000 records including
approximately twelve thousand today just
to give everyone specifics here as a
result we're talking about 97 percent of
the coal of the collection is now
available to the public this reflects
again the president's commitment to
making these records available to the
public to the greatest extent possible
consistent with National Security so
this is a commitment that the president
has been making for some time or made
some time ago President Biden believes
all information related to President
Kennedy's assassination should be
released to the greatest extent possible
consistent with again National Security
that's why he directed The acting
archivist to conduct a supplementary
six-month review of a of a subset of the
remaining redacted records to ensure
they are disclosed to the greatest
extent possible he also directed all
remaining redacted information to be
disclosed to the public when the basis
for the continued restriction of that
information no longer outweighs the
public interest so obviously there's a
national security component here but he
is committed to getting that information
out and right now we're seeing more than
97 percent of the collection that's out
there for for folks to to review
I have two questions for you Congressman
Cohen and Wilson from the Helsinki
commission introduced a resolution
urging President Biden to take steps to
suspend or terminate Russia's rights and
privileges at the U.N security Council
does the president support this effort
what steps he can take is this goal
achievable
yes
we do support that effort
um can you say the question one more
time I just want to make sure the the
resolution
says that the president asked the
president
urges the president to take steps to
suspend or terminate Russia's rights in
the U.S U.N security U.S Security
Council got it so um look Russia's
conduct in uh in Ukraine is is a
violation of the U.N a charter and is an
affront to the core Mandate of the
security Council and we see it as an
outrageous it is outrageous for a
permanent member of the U.N security
Council to be violating uh the charter
and waging such a brutal war on Ukraine
including by trying to inflict such
widespread human suffering and targeting
critical infrastructure so we
successfully led a vote in the U.N
General Assembly to suspend a Russia
from the U.N Human Rights Council and we
have work to prevent Russia from taking
leadership positions elsewhere in the
U.N system so we've been very consistent
on this if there were a path to suspend
Russia from the U.N security Council we
would pursue it immediately
unfortunately we don't see the U.N we
don't see the U.N rules changing and so
we are focused on continuing to take
actions to isolate Russia including an
international organizations and hold
Russia accountable including through
sanctions and enforcement actions we
announce today as you saw a follow-up on
Patriots for Ukraine also since there
was no announcement on this yet I would
like to ask if the president is even
considering sending Patriots to Ukraine
and what the White House's response to
warnings coming from the Kremlin about
possible consequences if the U.S sends
Patriots to Ukraine so first let me take
your last question first look the only
the only provocative moves are being
made by Russia and Russia is the
aggressor aggressor here and let's not
we should never forget that we should
never forget who is actually who
actually started uh this war and it was
Russia so that's that's point one point
two the United States is not now nor has
it been at war with Russia this is
responding to what we've heard from
Russia this past 24 hours we we've been
doing exactly what President Biden told
President Putin we would do one year ago
if Russia attacked Ukraine providing
security assistance to help Ukraine
defend itself that's what you have been
seeing from this Administration from
this white house finally while I don't
have any new security assistance
packages to speak of today as you all
know President Biden has been clear
about this the United States will
continue to support Ukraine for as long
as it takes alongside our allies and
partners as the people of Ukraine defend
their country as they defend their
freedom as they defend their sovereignty
and we will continue to do that but any
announcement this week as it was
reported by the U.S I just don't have
anything to share with you at this time
go ahead JJ thank you I'm wondering if
the White House has any reaction on two
bills that move through the U.S Senate
one is on Tick Tock that the Senate
voted to ban Tick Tock for a government
issued phones let's start with that one
does the White House have feelings on
that now so um as I've as I've said
before uh you know want to be very
careful on uh commenting on any uh
specific legislation at this time so I
would refer you to Congress on the next
steps we don't get involved in the
process uh as we've done in the past but
look just more broadly there are a range
of tech applications and products that
are not allowed to be used on the white
on the White House and other federal
government work equipment for security
reasons including Tick Tock we will not
go into any further details about
security policies that we have here but
I'm not going to get into the process I
know that this just happened so we're
going to let Congress move forward with
their process opposition on that one
what about the Senate bill that would
essentially halt huawei's access to U.S
banks the Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schuler is one of the sponsors of that
bill does the White House have a
position on that one no don't have a
position on that one at this time from
here
thanks
um Americans clearly divided about
immigration
from the White House perspective though
should Americans be supportive or
concerned with the end of title 42 which
obviously stops most migrants from being
able to apply for a sign what Americans
should know is that the president has
done has done the work to deal with what
we're seeing at the border since day one
what Americans should know is that the
president put forth an immigration
foreign policy to make sure that we're
dealing with a broken system to make
sure that we're able to protect dreamers
to make sure that we deal with the
backlog that we're seeing with Asylum
Seekers to fix the gutted system that
was uh that has been around for some
time but certainly was gutted by the
last Administration and the work that
the president has done he wants to do
this in a bipartisan way but what we're
seeing is Republicans continue to move
forward with political stunts many of
them are doing this and we continue to
see this for over the last several
months so the president has done the
work he secured record funding again I
mentioned 23 000 agents that are at the
border who are working night and day to
protect and secure the border and that's
because of the work that this president
has done and we're working on
anti-smuggling efforts as well and so
look uh what the what the American
people should know is that we have taken
the steps we're taking the step to
prepare for what is uh for uh for when
uh title 42 is lifted next week and you
saw that from the Department of Homeland
Security secretary myarkis was very
clear about that he laid out their
six-point plan when he was at the border
just a couple of days ago and this is an
Administration that has taken this very
very seriously does the White House
think that ending title 42 a trump era
policy is a good thing what I'm telling
you is that it was a court order that
was uh that we are following and we're
going to follow the law when it comes to
from what the court has decided to do
what I can tell you is what the
president has done over the last two
years to make sure that we're dealing
with border security we hear it from
many Republicans right you guys report
on it many Republicans say over and over
and over again that we need to do work
at the border that we need to secure the
Border but yet they refuse to work with
us on this piece of legislation instead
what they choose to do is do political
stunts that doesn't help
impression about Afghanistan there are
negotiations about including the Afghan
adjustment act and the spending bill
there's been a group of retired
ambassadors who have been pushing for
conclusion the Biden Administration has
tried to get this in the spending bill
before unsuccessfully what is the
administration doing differently this
time to get as you know by your
statement we strongly support the
ongoing Congressional efforts to pass
the Afghan adjustment act and we urge
Congress we're going to continue to do
this to send the legislation to the
president to provide a path to per to
permanent legal status for Afghans and
we have joined our communities and
resettled across uh who have joined our
committees and we settle across our
country through operation allies welcome
so that is something that we're going to
continue to ask for Congress to act we
first asked Congress to pass this
legislation back in August of 2021 and
have been working with members of
Congress from both parties to try to
pass it ever since and we know that
there is a bipartisan support for this
bill and that negotiations in the Senate
are ongoing it's important to take care
of our Afghan allies who took care of us
during the 20 years of this uh of the US
of the years that U.S was uh was at war
in Afghanistan so we take this very
seriously we strongly support it we're
going to continue to have conversations
with members of Congress and continue to
urge them to get this done
We Gather a few minutes
Jake Sullivan was in here on Monday and
set an engagement Russian counterparts
was playing
always
do you have any updates on that or can
say whether that happened so as you know
we want to be really mindful of uh of
any conversations that we have as we're
talking about negotiations so we're not
going to uh you know speak about that in
public I don't have anything to share
but so that you know and we've said this
before and Jake has been very clear the
president has a very clear we take uh
this uh when Americans are wrongfully
detained or held hostage we take that
very seriously and we are going to do
everything that we can to bring Paul
Whelan home that is a priority but
certainly we're not going to talk about
steps or any conversations in public
because we want to make sure that we get
this done
one other question can you give us an
update on mayor garcetti's nomination as
Ambassador India does the president need
to resubmit his name to the new Congress
but where are you guys at so look as you
know this is a priority and continues to
be a priority for us mayor Garcetti is
well qualified to serve in this vital
role the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee as you know voted mayor
Garcetti out of committee unanimously
after reviewing of this matter
thoroughly and we're hopefully and we're
hopeful that full Senate will confirm
him uh promptly and so we're going to
continue to support him okay good Emily
I have to follow up on title 42. I know
you said you guys are hopeful that the
Omnibus gets passed but what kind of
preparations are being done in case it
doesn't and communities do get
overwhelmed and need some resources and
also does the administration fear that
the end of title 42 will lead to a spike
in covet cases of the country so let me
just talk a little bit about the three
but there's three billion dollars for
Board of funding so a couple of things
uh you know again if Republicans are
serious about this we put forward some
uh three billion dollar plan uh that we
are asking for congress uh to support
here's what it would do it would ensure
that the men and women of the Department
of Homeland Security have the resources
they need to secure our border and build
a safe orderly and Humane immigration
system uh the funding will integrate
surveillance uh Towers inspect
technology border patrol rotary Wing
aircraft and helicopter aircraft sensor
upgrades tactical Marine time
surveillance system and also law
enforcement radios faster Asylum claim
processing and so much more so we
believe it's incredibly important to get
that done as well but to your question
about the the winter surge how we're how
Dr Shah was talking about this from from
the podium book because of the
president's president's work and what
he's been able to do uh throughout his
administration the American people have
tools we know what works and to protect
to protect themselves from covid and we
continue to encourage them to use the
tools as we always have now on title 42
we've inquired we are required by the
court to lift title 42 and we plan to
comply with that order and so but title
42 or not every individual encountered
at the border is screened and processed
by border patrol agents before they are
placed in removal proceedings and like
I've said a couple times already you
know Department of Health homeland
security has been on has been on top of
this we are prepared we are ready to do
this in a humane way and in a safe way
and so it is something that the
president has been working on since day
one of his administration
thanks everybody thanks everybody
gotta go thanks everybody